if you're getting killed on social media
or it's probably because you're killing
it you're crushing it it's like but
Chris was like at the epicenter that I
believe that what happened to Chris with
Will is the reason that that guy uh
made it okay for himself to jump on
stage to Chappelle at the Hollywood Bowl
I agree without that without what he had
seen at the uh at the Academy Awards he
probably would have stayed in this
seat it became in Vogue to smack
a comedian over a joke you don't like
which to me spoke speaks to me like as
that's an emergency that's what I was I
was in bed in Atlanta watching the
Oscars a year ago
um we're taping this Oscars week here in
Hollywood so it's exactly a year ago and
when he did that
um I said to my girlfriend I said if
Will Smith gets away with this I'm done
there's no no place I can work that'll
feel safe if Will Smith gets away with
hitting Chris Rock the biggest the best
his his Hollywood
colleague over a rose joke what help is
there for any
insult comic especially in this world
it's just over and luckily there was a
media blowback and and then beyond that
um the alopecia side of it was so
you know I'd always covered it up lied
about it you know I have alopecia I
always duck that conversation I didn't
want to be you know I didn't want people
to like think I was weird or or sick I'm
not I'm healthy but alopecia is one of
those things that
um I just went bald in a month so then
my eyebrows fell out then you know it's
like your eyelashes fall out and you
think you're dying you find out I'm not
dying it's an autoimmune disease and I
look at Jada Pinkett who's absolutely
beautiful
he makes a benign joke about GI Jane 2
which by the way I'm gonna be starring
in I don't know if I should be
mentioning that yet it hasn't been
announced but I'm gonna do it wow my
podcast
this is like a viral moment and if she
had laughed at that joke she would have
normalized this condition for hundreds
of thousands of people a lot of children
and my doctor who's a research Doctor at
Yale
um Dr Brett King he had told me uh uh
only weeks before that about a a kid a
10 or 11 year old kid who was wearing a
wig at school has alopecia and they
pulled it off and bullied her and you
know she killed herself somehow
and
I thought you know wow if
if Jada was able to laugh even fake
laugh
that would have helped so many people
destigmatize is that the word yep the
condition
and so I was personally
hurt by it and whereas forget that Chris
is my friend for a second forget that
I'm a comedian for a second like the
alopecia angle on it
kind of jolted me out of bed and made me
want to defend him and talk about that
angle on it yeah especially because she
used it she kind of weaponized
alopecia like you shouldn't mention it
you shouldn't make fun of right the fact
and it's not even making fun listen
comedy is not making fun it's making you
laugh or smile at something that is not
that's why they call it a sense of humor
because you have to sense the humor
where it's not so here is a young lady
suffering from an issue but so much so
that she looks beautiful enough to star
in a movie that kind of is depicted by a
bald woman you know in the front row of
the Oscars thousand dollar gown she
looks phenomenal and her her hair looks
phenomenal to her her non-haired looks
phenomenal she has a perfectly shaped
head where I look like you know Howie
Mandel if he drowned
oh
comparison Demi Moore was gorgeous yes
she she shaved her head for that movie
and I get that there's other arguments
that go the other way don't tell women
how to feel about their hair don't tell
a black woman how to feel about their
hair Chris Rock should know better he
made a documentary about black women's
hair and I go all of that is valid I get
all that but men also and children also
it's not happening to adult women it
happens to kids and it happens to me and
as if men don't care about their hair
it's a zillion dollar industry try to
say men's hair it's like obviously a
sensitive thing so you know I don't
think any one person gets to own that
conversation but Chris Rock weighed in
on it he didn't even know she had
alopecia right no he said that and and
either did the world so the people that
were like on Will's side even before
that I think a lot of people that were
on will side didn't know she had
alopecia they just thought no they knew
because she did a whole she did a whole
segment about it on her later no no no
she did a red a red table right that's
what's called yeah red table talk she
did a red table talk before that about
her alopecia so she's been open about it
and talked about it but but the beggar
point is like nobody cared it wasn't a
big deal it's not a health issue it's
just a Cosmetics she didn't seem to care
either she came out to DC stigmatizing
can I just stop for one second I just
want to shout out to Kenny our new uh
producer does the commercials and I just
put him in charge of the the board
behind us Kenny Kenny you didn't meet
Kenny but he's new with us anyway go
ahead
so I don't know my point is comedy is
King and we all need to loosen up and
laugh a little bit more
foreign